as anime fans we all know that the
medium is full of inspirational stories
a lot of the timeless classics and the
perpetual favorites all involve one of
the most classic storyline roots
the underdog story a lot of our beloved
heroes and protagonists go through one
hell of a challenge and the journey to
get to being the strongest is a long and
treacherous path everyone takes
different routes to get there we have
stuff where a protagonist goes from a
weakling to the most powerful being in
the universe throughout the course of a
season or multiple ones then we have the
one that's becoming more and more common
where the protagonist gets some
overpowered goods and practically
becomes an
in-universe god in the span of an
episode or two regardless here are the
main top characters that
embody the saying zero to hero we'll be
changing things up a little bit and
we're featuring
seven characters this time not doing it
in a countdown format oh before we get
started i'd like to say that nothing
would make me more happier than to see
this channel grow and have a lot more
subscribers as time goes by so with that
i'd encourage you to subscribe to this
channel and hit that notification bell
we're always looking to shake things up
here and i've got something very big
prepared for our next milestone
just be ready for it one last thing
spoilers are going to come out of this
list so
you have been warned
now when i think about a guy who turns
from loser to overpowered in just one
night
isakai leads come to mind with one of
the most notorious
examples of this in modern anime kicking
things off hajime nagumo there's really
not much to explain for hajime
especially if you're someone who watched
ari fiuretta i mean the title of the
show literally has the subtitle
from commonplace to the world's
strongest what happens when an issac
loser gets thrown into the abyss and
into certain death well desperation can
be one hell of a motivator
and with nothing to lose and the fire of
vengeance keeping him going
hajime manages to fight his way out of
the labyrinth a much more powerful
person than before
in the span of a couple of episodes he's
pretty much become the most overpowered
character in the ari furetta universe
he did have to go down and dirty though
but the challenges inside the labyrinth
that had him on death's door several
times were the last tangible hurdles for
him boasting an unmatched arsenal
incredible physical skills and a harem
of humans and monster girls that would
put naofumi to shame
hajime comes out virtually a god told
you the power to transmute is one of the
most broken ones when used to its full
potential
[Music]
let's continue with the shonen hero for
a change how about sooner
from hitman reborn
started off a useless kid who couldn't
talk to girls to save his life
and in the end a badass mafia boss of
the vongola and all it took was a
journey started by his meeting with
reborn
the cool part about tsuna is that his
journey to badass is something that gets
spread out throughout the series run
it's not as blatant and in your face as
a lot of shonen manga heroes journeys to
go from underdog to the strongest being
in the universe
but it is there we know what the dying
will bullets do to him but i actually
find more weight in his character growth
in the daily life segments
you see tsuna's development is a joy to
watch we were given those developments
in subtle doses and eventually
he overcomes his shell and becomes the
best ally you can have in times of
difficulty just look at the feats of
bravery that he's done without the need
for bullets
as mafia boss he's also an incredible
character that blows pretty much
everyone out of the water by the time
the series is done he's not the last
we'll see if shown in manga leads on
this list
so stay tuned
speaking of shonen heroes i think of
parasite shinichi
yeah shinichi is not a shonen hero
parasite's actually a seinen title from
way back
but still the point stands that he's a
success story of someone starting off
weak and then becoming strong
human monster fusions are some of the
most powerful beings in anime especially
when the two beings maintain their
individual wills and work together just
ask this guy
he goes from standard teenager to
parasite nightmare through his fated
meeting with migi who knew that a human
and a parasite working together would be
the crux to turning the tides of the war
against these aliens
the two work together and
single-handedly go through a gauntlet of
some of the toughest aliens in the enemy
side
in turn we get some of the best fight
scenes that the series has to offer
from many score fights to the final one
against gothor it's a perfect example of
characters starting out with teeth
clenched teamwork and a general low
standing on the power level scale and
evolving into becoming one of the
strongest forces in the series
not just physically but mentally as well
however it's the shared will and heart
that the two share which i'd consider
the most powerful asset that they have
[Music]
caught in a similar scenario to hajime
we have rimuru tempest
reincarnated as a slime he goes to the
same trials as the previous isakai hero
but instead of transmutation powers he
gets the ability to assimilate with
other creatures that he eats so what we
have here is pretty much a super version
of kirby and you can see where we're
going with this right all your powers
combined in the form of the most
powerful slime in the universe other
isekai leads just stand
no chance let me ask what's your answer
to an infinitely scaling slime god the
future is limitless for rimaru the
amazing part of it is that rimaru wasn't
even aware of his power at first just
look at his list of abilities on the
wiki and add on the fact that he's
pretty much immortal and we have one of
the most dramatic
zero-to-hero stories out there
is there anybody that embodies the
concept of going from weakling
to badass like ganeche does starting off
as a meek and weak student his life
takes a huge turn when he gets
transformed into a gould now things
won't come
easy and he refuses to accept his new
identity for quite a while
however when push comes to shove he
finally accepts his power and completely
destroys jason in one of the most badass
moments in season one eventually he
becomes some sort of mythological figure
and by the end of the series
it simply emphasizes how big of a
nightmare he's become
the thing about garniki is that instead
of becoming a straight-up heroic badass
he becomes more of an anti-hero as he
grows stronger
kind of like hajime from much earlier
how can we not have naruto in the list
his entire series is built and premised
on the ostracized kid dreaming big and
going from bumbling idiot to one of the
legendary figures responsible for the
village's legacy going forward what
makes naruto the series such a joy to
watch is that it's a slow
long and tough journey to see the
underdog create bonds
change people and find strength both
physically and emotionally some may
argue that the specific road to become
the celebrated hero of the village
concluded with the battle with pain but
naruto still went on and got some
at the end of it all we have one of the
greatest leaders that gonoh has ever
seen
strong enough with his fighting
abilities and the uncanny ability to
turn the edgiest people good with the
classic talk no jitsu yep
it seems that naruto is just the person
taylor made for a list like this
so how do you top off the list of zero
to hero stories
by transcending humanity such is the
case with who we're capping this list
off with
madoka
[Music]
for a series called madoka magicka our
main character sure spends
90 of the series being useless that's
not exactly an understatement and her
uselessness actually ties into the plot
and how it develops very nicely i could
probably do a long essay on the genius
of the series
but let's focus on the main character
for now you see that magical girl at
times she rocks in the opening
nowhere to be seen in all but the last
episode of the show madoka herself
spends the entire series crying
moping and questioning the intricacies
and nature of life and all of those
things
then the last episode comes and madoka
comes back with a vengeance
making her wish she transcends all human
boundaries and ascends to a higher plane
of existence
embodying the concept of fighting
witches madoka becomes god
quite literally rewriting the world not
even the biggest of her feats
as she goes back and ahead in time to
purify witches and changing the very
laws of the world
now that's a big swing in power if you
ask me
[Music]
that more or less wraps up this list
when making this list i decided to add
some more qualifiers which could explain
why some characters didn't make it to
the list backstory weakness disqualifies
characters so no sight armor despite the
huge leap in power characters holding
back or being misevaluated also get
disqualified from the list so sorry
ayato amagiri and tatsu yoshiba
although tatsuya himself is arguable
with those in mind do you think anyone
else could have quantified for this list
what do you think of me using this new
lucifer format instead of doing it in a
countdown form let your voices be heard
and start some discussions on the
comments section
for now that's gotta do it and i hope to
see you next time in the next video
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
sweet bell button so you can be the
first in line next time
you